beh ho intenzione di commentare bene come
vedrai nel titolo della presentazione
alla fine forse è perché è intitolato
in questo modo non lo dice inizialmente
è intitolato così perché abbiamo scelto a
porta come abbiamo camminato che è
vivere ma avremmo potuto scegliere
altri dobbiamo pensare che ce n'è uno che
abbiamo aperto ce ne sono altri che possiamo
rimanere
Non so se la mia presentazione è pronta
Bene, come puoi vedere, comincio con a
fotografia vietata ti commento
definitivo perché quella fotografia è vietata
Lo farò anche adesso, diremmo
una presentazione in cui nulla ha
a che fare con i miei social network perché io
puoi socializzare dove sono davvero molto
attivo penso di essere attivo di cui non parlo
la mia vita personale invece in questo
momento perché lo sei
esperienza quindi ho intenzione di farlo
Ti dirò che quando a casa mia tutti i
vita mi è stato detto che mia sorella è di più
intelligente ma che io sono di più
lavoratore
quando ero con mio nonno qualcosa che
L'ho adorato soprattutto perché mi ha portato a farlo
raccogliere frutta e potrei salire in alto
degli alberi sempre quando ci andavo
le nipoti hanno detto quanto sono belle queste
nipoti
ma araceli è quello simpatico
anche una delle cose che volevo
fare perché l'arte ha sempre
Mi è piaciuto ed è molto presente nella mia vita
doveva essere un artista, ecco perché io
Ho presentato belle arti ho presentato e non
è stato inizialmente accettato perché
avevano abbastanza talento per esserlo
un artista e penso anche di saperlo
Si sono accorti che avevo disegnato a
donna di spalle perché capelli grigi
sembravano davvero
e poi non sono entrato fino a quando
hanno fatto una media della nota che era
una nota che era un'informazione che I
hanno dato quando ero già a buon punto
documentazione che è la gara che
Anch'io ho davvero fatto carriera
che ho scelto un po' ignorante perché
Mi hanno anche detto di approfittare della nota ora
che è una carriera che avrà molto
futuro mi ci sono voluti tre anni per capire
che stavo studiando perché fino a
terzo anno non sapeva che relazione avevano
i soggetti non sapevano come fosse
plasmare la conoscenza fino a
Finalmente ho iniziato a trovarlo
gusto e davvero in questo momento è il mio
passione anche se resterò sempre
l'informatica ti dice che questa fotografia
cosa c'è è della prima ragazza che
Ho scoperto che stavi facendo un blog
Ebbene, come ho detto, il mio percorso è proseguito
stavo andando direttamente alla documentazione in cui ho lavorato
prima le biblioteche specializzate
della prodecommentazione europea ora
centri di documentazione artistica e non
Mi interessava solo quello che era
documentazione aziendale ma mi è piaciuto
qual era la documentazione in linea
possibilità di seguire una verità
navigare da un'informazione all'altra
un altro che cosa sarebbe l'ipertesto in quello
momento sto parlando di 2000 dell'anno
2000 documentazione realmente in linea
Ero interessato ma volevo anche
fallo con cui ho cominciato a prendermi cura di me stessa
diciamo che sono entrato in internet perché in
internet ha visto con uno spazio n
solo per informazione
documentare tutto ciò che accade
intorno ma era anche uno spazio di
creatività
i miei inizi sono stati attraverso a
giornale universitario online in cui
l'unica cosa che ho fatto è stato contribuire
informazioni affinché l'agenda culturale
è stato beneficiato fino al mio
fratello mi ha detto perché non l'ho fatto
di per sé un'agenda culturale allora
Ho iniziato nel 2002 quando Salamanca
Nazione europea della cultura' da fare
un'agenda culturale e sono diventato
stampa Ho partecipato a conferenze ai concerti
ballare eccetera dopo dopo
il discorso di dottorato che ho iniziato a fare
progettare pagine web di genere che il
dottorato che avevo scelto e l'ho fatto
con un editor di pagine web come
Dreamweaver in seguito è riuscito
sito web di due musei in cui ha avuto
il piacere di lavorare e poi
progettare il microsito in un modo carino
semplice e accessibile a tutto ciò che è
tramite wordpress per progetti molto
molto specifico
poi sono arrivati ​​gli strumenti 2 0 in
2004, cioè 4 anni dopo aver avuto
iniziato a creare pagine web davvero
È un lusso poterne avere un po'
strumenti che attraverso la stampa
di un'interfaccia molto intuitiva
permetteteci di relazionarci perché come sono i
i social network ci permettono di essere
fotografi
attraverso il ruolo di artista
consentono di condividere gli album
foto dei nostri viaggi
fotografie che abbiamo scattato
attività che possiamo progettare pubblicare
cosa sono
pubblicazioni online cioè tutto
possiamo essere autori del libro e twitter
quel twitter non è davvero lo sento
più comodo perché la mia testa si ferma quella voce
con le informazioni è un modo di
godere
ok ho usato avrei potuto
usato i social network per parlare
di oggi o come potrebbe essere uno dei
opzioni che è un'autopromozione e
per esempio quella fotografia che può
ricerca concordata
puoi vedere che si ripetono
davvero la mia intenzione è di non parlarne
tanto
dare informazioni relative al potere
condividere tutta quella conoscenza
che vado acquisendo andare
individuare l'organizzazione di queste informazioni
avere la memoria di tutti gli eventi a
quelli che frequento o quelli attraverso
streaming che grazie allo streaming
anche noi siamo ovunque
fa un file di tutto bene quindi questo
È l'immagine con cui ho iniziato il
presentazione e questo è mio fratello che sono io
Come ti dico una fotografia privata
e diremmo proibito all'interno di cosa
sarebbero i social network e cosa
fratello è uno scienziato informatico e cosa mente
devi sempre stare attento
dove appendi già tutti i tuoi contenuti
che gli strumenti le aziende che
gestire già tutti i nostri contenuti
sia nei social network sia in a
prezzo come è ora ne hanno alcuni
politiche sulla privacy che vanno
cambiando nel tempo e allora
È importante essere coerenti
consapevole di dove carichiamo il
informazioni ma ti incoraggio
Grazie